[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
preview preview sneak preview hello
hello hello and welcome back to the
break room this is our daily live show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news that you need to know live right
here from our studio on the surface of
the sun it's so incredibly hot it is
stop using micro plastics uh coming up
on the show today we're applying for new
jobs
because it's too hot at this place but i
want to work at an ice factory uh we
also got a thor deleted scene
we're not going to show it to you but
we'll tell you about it uh and we're
also revealing the results of our
she-hulk prediction she-hulk came out
last night episode three i hope you've
watched it i hope you saw the fun little
cameo that the cut spoiled uh and i hope
you enjoyed it we'll be talking about
today so if you haven't seen it yet get
the f out of here get out of here spoil
it
but before you go please hit the like
button thanks so much uh you know what i
learned you know what i learned
what like button very helpful thank you
so much
i say that everything the notification
bell during this show
is is really good that's correct i don't
know
i'm not a notification bell person but
if you are
unhit it and then hit it again
does that count if you unheaded and hit
it again let's find out i didn't learn
that break the system
uh i'm brandon
and uh here with me today giving tech
advice is john costa hello i am uh the
nerd he knows he knows the back end of
youtube like the back end of his back
end uh and across the table for me we
had koi jondro
wondering what the back end is the back
end of the back in the front end uh i
don't the no it's the underside yeah
like the paint you just got it
that's not what we were doing oh i see
before she walks away from the side
please give it up for jessica clemens
i'm so sorry we're talking about tanks
already it's all right it's hot our
brains are so hot i mean jessica's dress
is on fire
that's how hot it is uh
hey we got a great uh redemption rooney
for you all today uh after confirming uh
in uh
you just suggested a different
redemption oh i mean
i mean we talked about twerking on
camera but really only one of us here
would make it worth it and john wasn't
in the mood to do it no it's too hot you
should see john's twerk
it is it is life-changing yeah it's the
twerk that sailed a thousand ships uh
but we we might do some twerking if we
raise enough money who knows but our our
main redemption for today so on the
episode last night it was confirmed that
wong has a linkedin profile or at least
whatever the mcu's equivalent equivalent
of linkedin linked on it didn't have
like
one of those which i was missing i was
missing that like a little funny name uh
but good news
uh our inside source at marvel was able
to hack into the 616's
universe it's been terrible it's been
we have gotten in baby call us north
korea because we've hacked the circle
don't ever call us that uh tommy's on
his way uh uh we've hacked in from the
616 we've been able to pull some
linkedin posts now these are very
valuable items so we can't just show
them to you for free i wish we could our
lawyers won't allow it yeah but for
every hundred dollars we raised in super
chats we'll show you a real linkedin
post
from the 616 mcuniverse now i have been
told by our lawyers uh we had a very
generous off-screen donation so we can
show you one
to get to get you
excited for them okay benefactors yeah
we have benefactors mysterious
benefactors uh uh dasher can you throw
up can we see one of the linkedin posts
we'll give you a tease a freebie okay
okay this is from steve rogers
now he's an old man so he's behind you
know what it's like to have your
grandparents on social media he just now
is getting around to the blue dress gold
dress debate and that's how he feels
about it that's a joke that's the taste
tasteful he was gone he was gone he's in
another timeline with that dress
he's writing everything in the book and
now bucky has his books
yeah pull it up again
let's go around the table and relive
what what what year was that on the
screen it's wednesday 2013 maybe
2012
2014 2015.
um so yeah hundred dollars in the
superchat will get that and thank you
nina you for already sending in a great
super chat uh this heat makes me want to
twerk i'll tell you what you know what
else makes me want to twerk
headlines baby
oh john he's doing it he's doing it off
camera oh my god it's 12. you missed it
you missed it it's so good so sorry we
played that graphic while that was
happening it's incredible uh our first
headline today comes from an interview
with the av club uh where george miller
the director of uh mad max fury road he
revealed that he wrote his furiosa
prequel before they even started filming
fiore road that's how prolific this
australian man is wow uh he was saying
that he basically wrote the entire
screenplay before shooting fury road
because he wanted everyone to quote
explain to everybody who furiosa was to
charlize when she took on the role and
to all the actors and the designers and
everybody else working on the citadel
and so on so basically
he wrote himself a prequel so people
could understand what was going on in
the story have we heard of a director
making a show bible into a movie that's
kind of a cool thing because he's like
here's the backstory show bible and
meditation go watch the rings of power
tonight on amazon they turned the summer
into it well
rr was high on mushrooms writing at the
lord of the rings he didn't know about
movies there wasn't a it wasn't on his
radar
god didn't come down from the heavens
and explain that to us yeah yeah so he
wasn't he wasn't there yet you know what
i mean but uh this this is pretty ballsy
i mean george lucas was very smartly
like this is episode four yeah there's
got to be more right i don't know if he
knew what it was
ahead of time it was all up in his dome
uh i also like how would it feel to be
charlize would be like i read that i
loved it oh it's not me like what a
weird thing to be like i love this
character
i'm so invested i really love what you
did for the backstory oh i won't be
playing yeah
fury road basically is furious oh yeah
also right in my heart yeah in your
heart i mean uh he's he's
maxed up half the move he doesn't say
two words yeah
but honey sailor joy is great so excited
yeah yeah very excited to see the red
beard uh congratulations
i need to tell you guys
but also
i just enjoy big deer it's bushy yeah
crazy it really is incredible what
george miller's been able to do
especially because he has to film
everything upside down there in
australia it's very difficult i didn't
get it
uh next headline variety is reporting
that anya tale alan taylor
alan taylor is set to take over as show
runner on house of the dragons season
two uh so taylor he's going to be
overseeing the writing as well as direct
a few episodes now he's replacing miguel
sapochnick nailed it uh
who we who is the he's like the show
runner right now he's gonna be stepping
away for season two they're two show
runners there's
you're right there's a co he's a co-show
runner i apologize so they're retaining
one yeah
he's stepping away though miguel he has
that first look deal with hbo to develop
new so he's not going far away he's also
going to stay on as a producer for the
series in perpetuity i'm sure he'll
probably come back to directly in the
future whatever but he just wants to
step away for season two let this other
guy come in and alan taylor has
experience with the game of thrones
franchise so i think be fine not
worrying news i don't think he wrote the
everyone's favorite episodes of game of
thrones season eight which was
uh
yeah
that one i don't think that's in there
did he write no i'm kidding i'm kidding
i don't know
it was directed
it sets up avengers end game everyone's
favorite saga yeah you can't have it
they do a lot of great stuff in there
also i feel like him knowing game of
thrones is more important than anything
else he's done because this is that
world and like that that's sweet epic of
it all i'm excited it'll be great maybe
they'll bring maliki back in game of
thrones wouldn't that be nice stop
donating for the twerk fest oh yeah
we're getting so close to john's
twerking baby
next headline vanity fair may already
have the scoop of the month with this
report that nicole kidman is back in the
studio recording another amc ad
we can't wait to see this in front of
barbie which comes out next year hashtag
simulator get your ass down here come on
simon come on the show
are you counting he's not a cow no one
is not a joke no we want other people
now
uh so nicole kidman's making another one
of those beautiful amc ads and are they
really good or is it is the meme taken
over
is it really good oh yeah i think
sometimes something is so good it's bad
and then goes back dude it goes back to
good again i feel like we've gone full
it's an aura boris of greatness here's
what i said this is this article is from
uh is from the writer of the first ad
yeah whose name is billy frank billy
wright not cyrus i hope it's barry
very important he's like well i got a
text from i'm not gonna do that how dare
you give this man a night you don't know
if he has an accent billy ray cyrus oh
yeah if this you're speaking as billy
right yeah yeah no no no i was just
saying it's very funny to me that like
he got this article in the trades and
i'm sure he like
you know if if you get your name on the
train yeah
no no he's probably so excited
i mean he did write heartbreak feels a
little better in a place like this which
is an all-star winning line a killer
line that was actually ghost written by
alan uh taylor oh that makes sense i
kind of want nicole to like
uh um past the torch you know what i
mean oh we need her and the bedazzle too
you do a third in the third one she sits
down next to someone and there's a new
that's our new person
and it becomes this like title you pass
does nicole kidman have any kids that
act
do a little nepotism play they act like
they love their father oh got him got
him tom sorry billy ray i like the
prequel sequel reboot for the third yeah
you pass it along you go back to young
nicole kidman far and away what's wrong
with us
what's right
yeah yeah no more news
oh it's so hot in here it's very warm
but billy ray did confirm that it has
been written it's been written uh i
can't wait to see the next one we all
enjoy it leaked the script we should
have done that
next headline fandango's eric davis
revealed that as part of national cinema
day which we all love so much
celebrating
we're celebrating it this saturday
september 3rd a new sizzle reel will be
released and i'll feature footage from
upcoming films like black panther
wakanda forever and harry styles my
policeman wow it's a great film that we
all know about i am learning about harry
styles as my basement in real time
someone put that in the script to see if
i would just read it and not i i love
harry styles i've not heard of him
having a policeman so yeah uh if if you
do want to celebrate national cinema day
you could be gonna be able to get like
three dollar tickets for all movie four
yeah oh you know you can go see
rogue one back out in imax right now
uh well this is at the el capitan i
don't know if that's a national thing
sorry flyover states
no way home is back on no tomorrow yeah
yeah more fun
go see it for three bucks or something
uh we love the cinema especially the
overpriced popcorn next headline
deadline is reporting that reagan aliyah
did i say that right reagan aliyah
couldn't tell you uh has joined the cast
of marvel studios disney plus series
ironheart in an undisclosed role
mysterious let's pretty seriously right
now can we get our photo up do we have
our photo yeah oh great
oh
so fast okay
uh she's playing
i think she's playing tony stark great
stuff great first folks great stuff
i don't know i mean she could be like
another student or something like
because we know riri williams is going
to wakanda in wakanda forever
maybe like
she's still there maybe this is like
another student from wakanda someone
comes back to mit with her
koi's theory that she's not at mit she's
at the sort of like oakland
school
and that way like they they bring her to
that world as part of the ambassadorship
maybe she's west coast avengers baby
either one of those places would work
let's do it let's do it uh
in another headline
makeup and prosthetic effects company
odd studio showed a detailed look at the
dark shadow lord from thor love and
thunder i didn't even know who's called
this uh this was the guy who was the the
guy this was the person who was the
original wielder of the necro sword you
saw him at the very beginning in that
kind of oasis area this is where gore
gets the necro sword this was the same
company that also did gore's makeup and
prosthetics so obviously they worked on
other things well there he is look at
this beautiful dark shadow lord is that
like a fall i love him it's full of
prosthetics
there's not a person it's like a set
photo no there is a problem there is a
person in there okay um yeah yeah we
barely got a look at him no explanation
i wish uh this thor love and thunder
we're getting this spiderman no a home
more fun edition which is just sort of
like an extended cut of that movie with
all of the like behind the scenes drama
of cut scenes for thor eleven thunder i
don't think they would ever put out that
version but i do and hunting godzilla
yeah i would love some extended scenes
yeah yeah um
uh now just you and i have talked about
this like he's the dark shadow lord the
mcu has got to stop saying like shadow
realm shadow dimension yeah
because the dimensions and realms are
completely different like all these
shots and everything is shadow something
like that
is it all the same is it different i
don't know does anyone here know the
difference between a dimension in a
realm i imagine we had a long debate we
had a long debate because it's different
for them yeah and like a dimension feels
like it's it's a mirror a parallel a
realm feels like another area maybe
right but then like
yeah but the darkness
the dark dimension
but it's in our world i think that's
more of a realm that that would be more
of a realm in my in my definition kevin
come on the show
oh
wait we
we're way overdue someone's got to read
a linkedin post we gotta write a
linkedin post uh can we get into our
super chatters beautiful new linkedin
post up oh yeah here we go val valentino
alegre di fontaine head headhunter and
headhunter uh recently fired from your
government job due to gross misconduct
let's talk see that that photo is really
good she's online right now she has 99
notifications well whoever's linkedin
this was does not read their name it
doesn't have 99 notifications yeah if
you don't have 99 plus notifications on
your linkedin right you're using
linkedin with too much i just want to
check
follow me on twitter at con underscore
nope on josta cohn he'll respond on
twitter uh thank you to our super
chatters v-rail jsp contr contributions
to torah giallo's air conditioning
refurbishment fund i'll take it thank
you actually actually zach holston is in
his home because his air conditioner is
broke don't tell me don't tell the
people go find them don't tell people
that
uh elijah bowser also sending a super
chat uh the bigger hero threat to the
multi the multiverse is it reed richards
doctor strange or some other individual
yeah like a hero who's actually a
problem
and i've always said that doctor strange
is a problem and i think multiverse
event is confirmed that doctor strange i
would say across the universe our
problem
off is
a little bit more of a problem than the
old stephen strange you consider her a
hero then that was the question yeah it
wouldn't be fair otherwise yeah it
wouldn't be fair
i missed the original question which
hero
hero is the biggest hero that's a threat
to the multiverse like multiverse i
would say wanda i i feel like like she
would be a problem potentially anywhere
if she slipped as she did in ours and
she's always that powerful i imagine
she's a nexus being so pictured as dark
phoenix in the film dark phoenix it's
canon yeah but the phoenix is the
problem
but is scarlet witch the only nexus
being because what's tricky is reid is
clearly not nexus being because they're
probably going to cast someone else as
him but it seems like uh doctor strange
is a nexus being because el we only met
him as doctor you're getting into
something i think is really
i don't think marvel's getting they're
gonna test the next i don't think
they're gonna commit to
i don't think they're gonna commit to
variants having different looks means
that that person's not a nexus being
because loki they did both yeah and
that's tricky yeah cause like loki was
also him as president loki but he was
also talking about but they also kind of
throw in a thing of like loki's are so
crazy of course they all so many of them
look different because they have they
make such bold choices but also like
more you have to start as an athlete
right christine palmer is
yeah
guys what are the rules
what are the rules what we're here for
come on the show kevin feige uh we did
ask in a poll are you enjoying house of
the dragon more or less than game of
thrones more 60 oh they love the house
of the dragon that's cool i think that
uh it's yeah great it's great i love it
no i guess
i'm willing to say it's better than
everything uh we also got our first thor
for deleted scene via youtube
uh it's a scene where the gang enters
omnipotent city uh if you don't know
this uh
thor 11 thunder will be streaming on
disney plus day a week from today
september 8th i'm sure they'll release
all the deleted scenes they put all the
deleted scenes on disney plus as well so
that'll be fun then the blu-ray comes
out like a little bit later which will
probably have more deleted in behind the
scenes content maybe they'll have a
whole other hour and a half of a movie
who knows put it all in there you
cowards i mean i will say the scene was
really fun but it did feel like oh yeah
this would have slowed that movie way
down yeah
i'm curious about like what that hour
and 40 like they shot it sounds like a
four-hour movie yeah i'm wondering is
that other movie a slower paced movie is
that movie darker and they're more
inherently like more attention i think
all those things are true
yeah
well i think it was when you started
pulling at a strand yeah to cut it out
like it unrolled a lot of stuff and
you're like well we have to cut all this
just keep the fast stuff yeah yeah just
keep the fast stuff uh in the in an
interview with empire that we reported
on yesterday multiverse of madness
writer michael waldron also commented on
whether or not scarlet witch is really
dead he said quote she's removing
herself from the board for now forever
we'll see i'd like to see her again the
implications of that quote are
are destroying me yeah she's removing
herself from like she was like yeeting
out of this was she just dimension
like i'm gonna take a pause for five
minutes i think everyone thinks i'm a
child murderer yeah i gotta get out of
here i'm gonna go in timeout
i go back to that cabin and rest and
recover don't let things settle out here
in these child murdering streets i like
it uh
another headline here is she-hulk's uh
head
showrunner jessica gao told tv line that
viewers should not expect any more
cameos after daredevil lies lie big lie
or quote was i don't want to set people
up for disappointment
but i will say that the remaining cameos
are cameos from the comics characters
that haven't been seen before in the mcu
uh some of which we've spotted in frames
from recent trailers and promos uh and
kat koiro who directed episodes one
through four eight and nine who i think
is actually the show runner even though
i said jessica was just like a gal i
believe that's just the head writer my
apologies
there is no head right there there is no
showroom there is no showing it's true
uh uh she directs episode 13489 she also
echoed that sentiment telling tv line
that daredevil remains the biggest
surprise that we had which we let out of
the bag at comic-con
uh there's no way that's true i think
yeah i think this is all
just that that kevin feige phrasing yeah
yeah this is a little trickeration i
don't think that they would give away
their biggest thing unless they were
worried no one was going to watch it but
i i don't know i think there's something
else there there's a post-credits scene
that's going to lead to a thing that's
going to do it like they let this show
change shanghai like or put things in
shanghai to set it up so i think it's a
break
yeah i feel like she looks too big of a
thing to like not allow for those
moments at least at the very end yeah
right you have to get a you have to get
a huge reigns kang you have to get a
mutant sting at the end of the thing
you've got to get uh you know wanda with
the dark hole looking for kids setting
up multiverse like they do they always
do it i think the last episode is just
going to be a megan the stallion concert
megan the stallion chewie's two wees i
love how they say it on that show hey
everyone
but we did
help help i'm having a stroke we did
shield predictions yesterday yes can we
get the results of those up on the board
brandon is winning and so it's koi i
don't know why i'm singing you said to
give jessica another point jessica gets
another point the chat said no and i
agree with the chat what
because i think it's a democracy i think
we should all be able it's not a
democracy i make the decisions uh trash
bags you guys have 20 the graphic is
having a panic attack but that's okay
i'm having a time in there okay it's
more exciting
uh those are our results come back next
week we're going to be picking more
stories at the end of this at the end of
the series i know we only show like who
got points when they're on the show
today at the end of the series we're
gonna do points for everyone that's
contributed are we not breaking down
what the points were
uh if we get that graphic up i could
maybe remember
jen went on no dates so no one got
points for that
uh and i think you got five points for
yeah yeah you were all over paroling uh
no i think she you took the uh
i took the over
i think we both got over we're gonna go
because during the episode zach was the
only one that went under mm-hmm
okay well i have to look at my notes
[Laughter]
we might need to make a correction we'll
deal with that next headline
you guys
tis the season uh it's she-hulk season
and uh epic hero shop has some really
great she-hulk merchandise uh that we
think you should check out because
spring and i like our little twins
t-shirts
we
the new rockstar's newest latest
obsession is called lady justice and
it's available now on
newrockstarsmerch.com there it is
sitting beautifully next to our new ash
and ruin shirt inspired by the
targaryens in the house of the dragon um
so check both of those out on a new
rockstar yeah they're those both of
those shirts are limited dish limited
dish
coming down the pike we've got andor
merchandise coming at you if you're big
star wars nerd uh or you know someone
who's a big star wars nerd
get him a little gift we also got our
rings of power sure
i think so oh that's right yeah yeah
look out look out
you guys are gonna watch rings of power
this weekend right try absolutely i'm
going to watch it tonight just squeeze
it in put it on the barbecue it'll be
great
all right enough talking about rings
ninety percent
of people thought i think yeah we're
gonna see another mcu cameo
let's talk about long baby let's talk
about you and me uh after his appearance
in episode three wong has shown that he
clearly operates outside of the laws of
man okay this guy does not care he shows
up when he wants he doesn't care for
your courts he doesn't even know what
the law is
do we think that there's something more
sinister to these actions okay i i have
some suspicions and this was really
daschle kind of planted this seed in my
head and has grown into a sequoia of
truth uh
could wong be a part of whatever this
thunderbolts yeah lineup is going to be
okay
the i think the biggest thing i did also
this morning when we were talking about
what we were going to do for the show
today i laughed it in dashiell's face
when he was like long thunderbolts and
then we sat there we thought about it
more and we were like oh my god yeah are
they setting up wanting to be a part of
that and then you said it to me and i
was
and they're like no there's this
headlight i was like okay yeah we're
gonna convince you about it i'm ready
because i'm about to have that moment
let's start with abomination okay he
goes in he takes the abomination out of
breaks him out of prison he knows he's
in prison because he's like oh i need
this guy so i can fight
in this tournament even though that
tournament wasn't like the
sorcerer's supreme tournament right just
like part of the overall i guess there
was maybe like different places around
the world you had to fight in like
different separate tournaments uh to
show that he sources are supreme and
then he puts like abomination back like
why risk it all for about why is
abomination the guy you have to fight
like you fight like anybody else you can
fight your friend bruce you can fight
your friend tony you can fight
just an iron man suit that is programmed
to fight you oh god i also think it's
probably best to go to someone like emil
because he's kind of a third party
person and he's not gonna ever waver in
a fight like i don't think tony would
either i don't think hope would but we
don't really know where bruce is and i
don't think they're actually friends but
i think making friends
yeah but i think wong making friends
with someone that we don't see often
would make more sense than someone from
the avengers now how do you think wong
got in touch with a meal
hi ku
haiku
do you think someone named uh val could
have like connected them and said like
hey i got a guy you can use for your
little how do we think about the fight
won't know their bad guy like what if
what if val is the bad and the
thunderbolts they they play with
expectation and they're actually good
guys they're doing bad things
if johnny manning is on your team you
heard about his public accounts oh
that's true well the u.s government has
to be doing the us government has to be
doing so much well it was already open
yeah you can't put it back in the box
when everyone saw it online no you
absolutely you can but everyone saw it
already
the person he killed was a terrorist
well everyone the thing is if
you want to think inside the box like
that i i guess it depends on who you're
talking to because i feel like there's
people in the mcu that'd be like well
let's hear from both perspectives
i'm just saying like as as if val is
representing
some kind of shady government entity
which she may or may not be doing right
you could throw all the propaganda at
the wall about uh john walker and bail
say you know oh that clip you saw you
know that wasn't him doing something
disgusting and horrible that was him
doing something great and heroic
i'm talking about the people that are
already going to be on the thunderbolts
so elena i don't think she would believe
that
maybe because i'm saying elena might be
the bad that's manipulating these these
people after haka i think she's changed
yeah like he talked to her she cried and
she walked away
she recognized that like this is true
that is definitely a growth moment well
what if what val is putting together is
are the avengers she's going to get
johnny
she's going to get
uh elena she's going to get these people
and she's putting together what she's
calling the avengers uh and they're
going to be right they're going captain
america she's got a hawkeye she's got a
black widow she's got a uh a hulk with
abomination they're doing it
they're doing like a dark avengers kind
of thing where it's like no we're the
good guys we're the avengers because
avengers used to be part of shield and
then when shield dissolved they were a
private entity funded by tony stark
let's say they're going back to the
government what's the government right
now it's sword it's shield or sword
dc yeah they're putting together the
avengers these avengers are going to be
the bad guys and like you're saying the
thunderbolts are going to be the
underground good guys like working
together to like stop these guys totally
like supporting everything a little bit
of civil war yeah yeah and i think civil
war but to a team scale again makes
sense especially with what we've seen
with ms marvel with the dodc i think
inevitably we've got a team versus team
fight coming but it'd be fun to play
with expectations i like that too
brandon keeps saying that's not gonna be
that movie is not gonna be called the
thunderbolts and it's gonna be called
something like young avengers young
avengers versus thunderbolts i think
that would sell both right that would be
a great way you're just going to spoil
it yet until i mean maybe next week yeah
we also saw wong
could one also be playing both sides
right because we have the shanxi like
post-credits scene where he's meeting
with captain marvel and bruce via
hologram and he's got the ten rings he's
like oh they're alien
but then like he could also still be
working with val cause like i don't i
think
wong doesn't seem sees morality in like
an interesting way and like separate
from governments and like institutions
and i think he kind of saw how like
stephen got manipulated by the avengers
in different ways he's like no i'm not
gonna let that happen to this sorcerer's
supreme i'm going to keep thinking i'm
going to play
for whoever has the is most right in
that situation that's why i don't think
he's going to be on a team i think he's
just like i think there's so many duties
as the sorcerer's supreme to even think
about this and even like
just the thought of like the the scope
of what the young avengers and the dark
avengers will do versus what he does
it's like my stuff is metaphysical your
stuff is literally on this planet i go
beyond this planet i don't need to be
involved with your chaos but also uh
which val could get rid of uh wong is
technically a wanted man
yeah
so
also everyone is probably sitting here
saying like what
i said a wonkton man oh there you go
oh i'm sorry i shouldn't have brought
the attention back to you i'm ready for
wong's sort of villain arc right
everyone is like oh thank you steven
strange you saved us from maximum off no
one you saved
it's a problem thank you so much uh uh
you should be the sorcerer's supreme not
this other guy
and uh what if wong
is a skrill okay um here we go
i'm ready for this conversation
it would explain how he's trying to
build up power to maybe allow for the
cru scroll war we're going to see in the
marvels to come into play so what if
he's trying to destabilize what if he
broke abomination out just to
destabilize i like it and therefore he's
not working for anyone he's just trying
to undermine any sort of system to allow
chaos from the scrolls invade how does
wong know everything then if he was a
scroll
right maybe he's been scroll for a long
time yeah if he's been a scroll the
whole time yeah like he's been like he's
been scrolling like their entire time
yeah
the whole time and i will say we keep
saying like who's gonna be a scroll
who's gonna be a scroll i can't be
anyone it can't be anyone with a huge
name because they gotta be in the show
blah blah blah
wong's been in so much could be perfect
and we wouldn't expect after his is nick
fury that he'd be the guy yeah well and
and we might get into this a little bit
more uh in depth sometime this week but
it is interesting right that judge price
or the the person impersonating megan
the stallion and all that kind of thing
like why wasn't that character a scroll
right setting up secret invasion yeah
the asgardian why did like
an elf that shape-shifts right
i have to think the writers were like oh
yeah she's a scroll and then someone was
like no we're saving that for secret
invasion because we don't want to miss
like you don't want to show too much
squirrel to have us thinking about it
and since they haven't shown a scroll
we're not thinking about scrolls since
captain marvel i think the next time we
see a scroll is marvel's and then i
think there's an immediate i think the
end of the marvel's is secret invasion
set up i think we're like oh blah blah
is a scroll and then that that's the
cliffhanger i've been thinking i was a
scroll for the entire time
i i think he yeah yeah i think like i've
of course he is he's been featured in
everything that's not that's what i'm
thinking that's why well which which
does come up first secret invasion of
the movie can we pull up that phase five
graphic for real fast
do we have a date
for secret invasion we don't but they
sort of they sort of placed it that's
before the marvels oh yeah so so
that wouldn't work that's so weird hey i
love your theory i love your theory
you're completely wrong completely wrong
but the long stroll thing could still be
true could still be true could still be
true well green not attending a super
chat i love addressing this all the time
could wong be a skrull since he
technically doesn't have powers super
scrolls babies yeah there are and there
are scrolls that can do magic in the
comics they can learn how to do magic
it's adorable so uh because we've
learned we know that different alien
species can do
magic because at the end of guardians of
the
galaxy
written like solution like
he's a magic scale can someone should
someone clarify this for me real fast
you have to have like
born magical ability to be a sorcerer at
commerce and all that kind of thing you
can't just like roll up and be like i'm
a guy teach me because they had jacob
battle on uh they had him right i
mentioned
the fingers
i think it's like one of those like we
all have the the power inside of us but
more gifted and like more tapped into it
and so you could you could grab a scroll
off the street and theoretically enough
at a thousand hours right you put that
scroll you push them you pull you know
you
you find the right scroll you get them
there you get them there
uh they can do the magic it's fine uh
do so do you think going back to our
long discussion how he's clearly a
scroll and he's evil and he's gonna do
bad things do you think
that there are an avengers right now
there is a set avengers team at all no
no sam sam wilson's on a shrimp boat so
when
i know but when going back to shangshi
at the end
when when they when wong is talking to
captain marvel and bruce yeah
it was that that's all
on wong's time
yep he's doing that on his own because
he sensed the rings he and he tells that
he tells chung cheese like oh all the
lights and bells were going off over
here at commerce as soon as you got the
rings right when the uh when when
obviously they didn't know for a
thousand years didn't do anything about
it yeah uh where were you
magic guys you put one more coin in the
bucket of wong as evil right yeah
letting wenry run shop and as soon as
that gets shut down he's like whoa whoa
whoa let me take this right to my house
he was the librarian of the commerce for
how many years he's read every dark book
under the sun probably he's probably got
little library tags on every little uh
you know little little uh artifact that
is he's kept at every sanctum
in the world um and he was like here's
another item that's super powerful for
my evil collection of fun things yeah
you could have the stupid flying cape
stephen i don't care yeah so no official
avengers right now
i think i think the gathering of a team
we've only seen through wong and i don't
think there's any other he was just
doing that because he was worried about
these magical artifacts yeah that's why
captain marvel was like who is this i
have to go right don't call me ever
again lose my number wong
lose it
uh thanks to all our super chatters out
there scott chang saying big up in our
love from the uk hey hey top of the
morning to you oh my god
get in the queue and take the lift and
enjoy some chips with your bangers and
mesh uh
uh also got a super chat from
sir psycho sidekick saying five dollars
for a saga shirt excellent choice rip it
off
rip it off seriously that's brian series
also sir psycho sidekick saying hey guys
i'm currently packing for my move to
boston yeah
going to bean town thank you for the
break room being the break i need love
y'all hey make sure you wrap those
plates up with extra newspaper you don't
want to lose them on the trip and make
an inventory of your boxes put a number
on each box and then make a spreadsheet
and say what you have in each right next
you can pack your socks and underwear in
your glassware that way it's uh
cushioned and then you save space
about our dimensions talk saying
dimensions are planes of existence that
are stacked on top of an anchor to
single universe realms exist in their
own plane and are not world or universe
specific they can span multiple
universes which is interesting but i
would also counter like the dark
dimension kind of is one dimension that
ex that can stretch into every universe
i see as the dark dimension in between
universes do you think they see the
competition i'm so confused about your
theory because the dark dimension is
just pieces of other
like dimensions i think it's like the
the mortar in between the bricks of
different interesting things so it flows
and that's what i think that's what
causes incursions because when you're
dream walking you're utilizing dark
dimension energy and you're breaking
you're breaking down that mortar between
the bricks and the bricks start cracking
into each other so it's just like here's
two balls here is the the start yes the
dark shaft between the balls okay
you know what the dark dimensions you
started this analogy i just it i think
mine makes more sense because
yeah
i think they want us just chasing our
tails with this nonsense uh you guys
think christy is like either an ai or uh
catfish i think christie could be kevin
feige potentially just posting things in
that keeping us in check constantly
chrissy i don't believe you uh i believe
you christy it's okay don't listen to
john uh it's hot in here we're sweating
a lot the planet the planet's changing
guys uh and it's true we can have this
argument about whether it was man-made
or not but it was man-made get your
heads out of your asses but what if
there was a credit card that helped that
can help you tackle your negative impact
on our climate just by using it once a
day uh there is and it's called the
aspiration zero credit card aspiration
zero is the first credit card that
fights climate change by planting trees
with every swipe i could use a hundred
trees over this building right now to
give it a little bit of shade you plant
two trees with every purchase you make
when you use the aspiration zero credit
card which soaks up about the same
amount of carbon dioxide from the air as
the average american puts out every day
plus two trees look so great we all like
the twin pines mall we don't like the
lone pines mall it's much better the
first way uh and along with all the
great benefits you get with the
aspiration zero credit card you get
unlimited one percent cash back on all
your monthly purchases when you hit
carbon zero for the month which is great
aspiration has already planted 75
million trees
so many trees uh one tree for each
grievance my wife has against me wow
incredible uh make your thoughts make a
difference she's not watching it's okay
i'm doing this it's like it's like
fanning you getting a little bit yeah uh
make your dollars make a difference and
apply for the aspiration zero credit
card today
and earn 300 welcome bonus after
spending three thousand dollars in the
first 90 days apply right now at
aspiration.com break room to go carbon
neutral effortlessly and earn a 300
bonus that's aspiration.com break room
the aspiration zero mastercard is issued
by beneficial state bank pursuant to
licensed by mastercard international
incorporated good credit is required and
terms and conditions do apply
that's it that's our show
no no no here here's the real here's the
real deal folks behind the scenes
and this hot hot day john tried to
cancel something uh
and jessica and i love these we dug
through the ashes of this fire that had
burnt out we found the coals and we
fanned them we gave them a little bit of
air and what do you know the fire came
back and that fire burns bright and it
burns bright for mandatory fun
simple graphic
did you play i didn't tell you to play
graphics why did you play a graphic you
better play it again don't be mean to
evidence play it again
there's this thing we do where sometimes
we get oh yeah we tend to be angry at
production
and part of that anger is you gotta say
playback graphic again
he's good that was quick that was good
i can hear you in the mic play my face
six graphic let's see it empty desolate
unfulfilled
spring 2025 is gonna be the new mutants
we're doing it again baby get it out of
here get it out of here okay listen guys
we love seeing megan the stallion on the
show last night and celebrating her
ouvoir of music uh but there's other
music out there by other uh important
people
uh it's the long show
this is the wong show today uh in honor
of the wong show we we put together some
some wong songs
this is why i wanted to clap this game
all right so jessica
we captured we kind of captured this we
had a little time so we put together
some won songs
rather mccoy and john participated
because it's cruel and it's mean to do
uh but we love our rap songs so you're
more than welcome to take a rap
jessica's got a couple rap songs do you
want to go first or i'm going to do one
of my first there's many okay i've got
two quick i'm only doing the chorus oh
boy
you wanna go first huh you wanna i can
do this you do one first okay so brandon
kind of we got these how do we get these
again
uh well we have an insider at marvel we
got inside our marble and we skimmed the
wall with a grappling hook yeah yeah
i've been all week yeah tommy's been
acting as as the uh the on-site medic at
marvel and i found this song and um she
found this song a nice pair of dress
shoes by the door oh it's called big
wong energy oh okay
it's really good you guys i'm gonna
start by
i could be your fantasy i could tell you
got big wong energy it ain't too many
wizards that can handle me but i might
let you base me like rochester
let them read like a book like a mystery
and if strange ain't right i got the
remedy it ain't too many words that can
handle me bad [ __ ] i could be your
fantasy oh
that's pretty good how do we feel about
this one is it good to go it's pretty
good
it's going forward now my now when i was
sneaking around the office i i snuck
over to the country western division of
marvel oh my god they're putting out a
country album for wong damn okay uh in
this song
you know it's singing along i'm getting
too this one's called wong open spaces
okay
uh this is just like i'm gonna give you
a little verse of course at the end
he's gotta get out of his mother's
garage
gotta leave home head to comatage don't
laugh doing magic makes him feel so very
merry
even if he has to work in the library
he needs
long open spaces
room to make a sling portal
he needs
new faces
make magic makes them immortal magic
makers
that's serious it's a really good
freaking song
country music television awards are
going to be wrong
can we acknowledge that i tried to sing
a lot you guys remember those 90s ads
when it was like two people going like
and that great hidden yeah we're doing
that for a while that is happening uh
and this one this one i also found i
found this one in the cafeteria that was
in the cafeteria and you know they have
like three cafeterias
so
hands on my whip singing songs on my
wand crap post you a pig better make it
a thirst trap win a mill hit then a
[ __ ] getting way back where the [ __ ]
you in the clubhouse is while and i've
been at commentary one [ __ ] walking like
a pump on a leash let's talk it sorcerer
or the supreme i'm top [ __ ] little [ __ ]
that's losers hating on me from target
oh my god
i want another verse that's so good this
one's good to go i mean when they put
off the album
now this one i found in the dressing
room okay okay oh uh where people get
dressed
at work at marvel this is at marvel
studios oh
follow the plot of the story i thought
you were broke i thought we were at
marvel headquarters where like in office
yeah they still have a dressing room
they got a gym there people got to work
these guys
with the hat
uh planet fitness guys okay this one's
just called wong song
i know this whole segment's called wong
songs but this one's called wong song
okay
oh that magic's so scandalous and you
know another wizard couldn't handle it
so you slinging like rings like who's
the wiz with the look in your eyes so
devilish
you like to live live you like to live
and commentation you run that place like
you the boss not just know paul he like
the buzz because he living in new york
city he's got slings like a ring ring
ring gems that bling bling bling stephen
move your butt but but i think i sing it
again he has a spine like a book book
book a title he took
took all night long yeah what let me see
that one
baby
that one
baby girl
and i can't sing in the key of what i
think this is charlie i think charlie
puth wrote this one oh okay it's called
charlie booth come in right there says
you turned me on like the benedict
i
i don't know why they didn't name it
after wong
after that did it
um you turn me on like the benedict when
you're whipping your sling ring around
now i don't wanna fight this no no no
you gotta sing this with me you know i
know the words oh it's okay you know how
to just make me want you turn me on like
the benedict when you're watching the
compound around and around
you got me with the tight whip
you know you just make me want you
he didn't finish it oh charlie
get back to work uh we did get a a lot
of super chats thanks for all those
super chats you guys have been sending
in today uh we do owe them another
linkedin post since we've been talking
about stuff we stole
from uh
oh
marvel here you go this was from uh
black garbolt again oh no uh king of the
humans and motivational speaker uh can
you all do me a solid and stream all the
episodes of inhumans on disney plus this
weekend trying to get a reboot going
lots of finger cross emojis also feel
free to drop an endorsement poor link
didn't con out any humans felt wrong
yeah
red squiggle yeah they don't like it
rude they don't like it rude as hell
rude as hell
next headline
we got another headline no i just been
screaming that today oh i i like that
little baby this is uh
something we want to talk about today uh
we got a new episode of she-hulk i don't
know if you guys know that oh we did
yeah we got a new episode it was really
fun here's the thing they keep going
after blood keep going after jennifer's
blood
it's freaking weird uh and we're just
trying to figure out like
is the blood going to be a thing in this
show i think it has like they mentioned
it's gotta be so like okay if we're
talking about mentions of this this
she-hulk blood right bruce was like hey
i spent two billion dollars on r d on
this weird machine that does way too
much to destroy people's blood okay uh
and then in this episode you know we
have the uh
uh someone remind me of what that group
is called please wrecking crew the
wrecking crew like trying to jab her uh
in the neck to get something
too much too much uh stuff looking for
jennifer's blood obviously like
you know bruce with his inhibitor chip
sort of bled into
jen's cuts and that's what turned her
into a shield abomination has some of
bruce's blood in him a lot of blood talk
uh if you're squeamish
uh
we're not showing anything
this is going to lead us into a couple
of paths right
uh
a number one
like okay so like who is going after the
blood right who is sending these kids
essentially with insanely overpowered
weapons
to
go crab jan walters blood and might
suspect number one
i know people don't want to hear this
because people like this character
which is unfair
um
the power broker the power broker the
lab in badger poor destroyed no more
uh super soldier serum
she's still gotta
run a business yeah i mean super soldier
serum is like the biggest mcguffin of
the mcu yeah it's been around forever
you know
it's important i would i would put like
thunderball ross on the case too because
he that's how we got abomination in the
first place he's trying to make his own
serum he did make his own serum uh i
would i could see him trying to steal it
i mean the bigger question is it's not
it can't be anyone from the government
because they have emil blonsky locked up
in theory you could just take his blood
now i don't think his blood works the
same as a wall as like a pure bruce
banner's family that genome they talk
yeah like i think that's important like
he he's he's when you know uh you have a
horse and a donkey have sex all right
and you get a mule the mule can't
reproduce is that true yeah yeah uh
century boys
donkeys burrows and mules and it's all
different combinations of horses and
donkeys having sex i have never known my
whole life did not know this they're
important distinctions
it also depends on what is male and what
is
on his own he can't make new hulks on
his own right but like uh if you're in
bruce's family line or you have that
weird genetic manipulation you can
spread it somehow because like an
incredible hulk right he drips a little
blood uh that stan lee drinks and i
forget if it kills that character or it
puts him in the hospital or something
like that yes so that's when bruce
how dangerous his blood was right or he
knew because he was trying to stop it
before it happened but that was like
proof so that's why he has this thing
that i think destroys more than just
blood but he uses it to destroy
it's only pretty blood uh obviously her
blood is gonna be a big important thing
in the show
uh i think it's interesting that the
wrecking crew has as guardian
construction equipment yeah i don't know
if that was just for like convenience
sake to explain away technology or does
this originate in as new asgard i think
it's like the how vulture was able to
scavenge the tech they want to say
there's not still i imagine
yeah this is our alien exactly like this
is the evolution of that concept i
imagine whoever sent them has cultivated
weaponry from all over the place right
okay so i like the idea they've got an
armored poker right right he's like
dealing in artifacts and things like
that i don't think it's played i don't
think it's more obvious i don't think
it's vampire based i mean
it's not too late
to take it back
on social media
but really but really right like okay
you gave a bunch of kids who have
seemingly never gotten in a fight with
anyone before because they were so
unequipped for that fight but those a
bunch of praise was good
great dance a bunch of crazy technology
and expected them to beat up this person
and take her blood like who's doing that
right it makes no sense i think they're
testing i think that was a test for
jessica i mean jennifer walters for me
it's for you
i think it was a test for her they
didn't actually think it would succeed
like they thought maybe on a fluke but i
think that someone that's going to be
testing oh i want to see exactly how
strong she is yeah i think they were
getting like i think it was a test do
you think it's like
gl kh
a little bit like i don't think it's
within that world i think it's gonna be
a super villain
i mean it would make sense to be like
kingpin or something like that well yeah
because let's talk about funding
we we don't even know if we're getting
matt murdock in the show we do know
we're getting daredevil right that's a
good point um and it feels like the
opposite should be true right it might
be like oh yeah matt could show up in a
courtroom that makes total sense but but
all we've seen is is the daredevil
costume right and so like theoretically
there has to be a reason why he is in
los angeles
unless she goes to to manhattan uh
fighting crime right um so maybe that
something is bringing him in here it
could be a kingpin
i think flies to l.a and he has his
daredevil outfit in his
he's like not completely accurate
almost cheap and then closing
i think if we're keeping it in the world
i
i always keep pitching on rogue theory
on everything we've done i keep pitching
the leader but i do realistically think
that it's a leapfrog
i'll leave franchisee
i think
because i think
um
mt is on it saying that lee frog's dad
is the guy that jumps out the window and
lands on the car without injuring
himself okay and i think leapfrog is
trying to like either get in good with
his dad or trying to make up for what
his dad did i think all of what we saw
that is like leapfrog's a good person
he's gonna be a superhero is not true i
think he's gonna be the villain and i
think he has a team of goons who are
really bad you are them because i don't
think wilson fisk would get another
shitty crew after what the jumpsuit
mafia did and i like
this kingpin guy cannot hire him
and then same with val i don't think val
would hire a team so reckless and bad so
i think it's going to be someone that's
an up-and-comer that doesn't really know
how to hire a crew and i think they were
lured in with like you can also get a
portion of her blood if you get it
interesting and they're like hell yeah
and then they got their ass kicked and
they're probably i'm not gonna fight her
again interestingly the chat is split on
whether abominations blood has powers
they say 51
yes
i just feel like they would have drained
him already like the government would
have been like we'll take that blood i
guarantee they're doing testing and i
think maybe that'll come in to play
thunderbolts in the super soldier serum
coming back because i do feel like in
the comic books that's a long running
like there's some continuities that tied
even to the weapon x probably oh yeah
there's so many times that's yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like versions and yeah
yeah i get to them bringing that back in
some capacity and maybe mix the
bonnation's blood or something oh you
know what i'm saying their blood might
just all be really different watch
abominations blood actually like die on
him of oxygen unlike
the other ones graveyard depraved gourd
sending in a super chat pointing out mr
sinister loves blood samples
get me my jon ham mr sinister baby bring
him in you know who else he was supposed
to be him oh he was full of cast yeah he
was supposed to supposed to be in it
with the remember the the suitcase yeah
he was like filming he filmed this
with
i was a kid watching that and i was like
what the hell is this thing
yes
i want jonathan so bad i want john
so bad what is happening oh so much mr
sinister awakening inside of all of us
[Music]
the jubilee trilogy uh it's going to get
announced at d23
next weekend jubilee gaming
we do have a jubilee scoop that we will
not share on air but it
is coming uh
elijah bowser a long time fan of the
show uh we've only been doing the show
for like three months says you do
realize
all right
like that we were connected with aunt
may so it impacted not only the
character
what if the mcu is doing that with wong
so at some point to kill him off later
oh they're just we're just trying to
like they're just trying to be nice to
long i said wong would die eventually
and you guys were the one that got mad
at me for saying that's vital we all die
eventually well i mean like i think he's
gonna die like within the story
kang's gonna kill him he's gonna he's
gonna pay the ultimate prices and ben
mcmahon's gonna be like thank god and
everyone else could reckon
i'm out of here
one day i'll become a real youtuber says
commando coy look here's the thing it's
105 degrees in london i'm in the breeze
that's okay coin went into the deep
valley yeah for a toy i did i did
frankly
you guys are lucky i'm not commando and
killed because it is amongst my people's
right to do i'm right next to you you're
irish yeah but like i i look like i can
wear anything i got that scottish ness
that's true hey hey trash folks thank
you so much for watching our show today
uh we're gonna be back here tomorrow
talking more can we give them a few
linkedin yeah
yeah
we're not gonna be here on monday we're
not gonna be here on mondays
i'm getting out of here i'm going to
freaking new orleans yeah look at this
from the real vision uh the real vision
this poor guy he's just trying to figure
it out he's just trying to learn uh he's
just trying to learn what what the
internet is he doesn't know how
computers work he's new he's doing this
world we got another one i think
uh sam wilson captain america formerly
knows falcon am i connected to anyone
who works for a bank or lending
institution
someone pay sam wilson give him some
money someone pay these avengers man
tony you know tony was paying them it's
wrong you know tony was paying them is
that all i think there's another one oh
yeah yes
bring it back
don't let confinement can find you
nobody can be the prison warden of your
mind you determine your own reality also
please send some cash through my canteen
fund need more honey buns uh poor
doesn't hammer it's working in a cell
alone twerking all alone on a sound so
sad i love the idea that he's like a
tony robbins fan like the idea he's like
a motivational speaker like addict with
those orange hands i think i think we
stole another one i think there's
another one oh
oh she's the best
nemo with a put down put him down i mean
i can't choose he might be the best
dancer in the mcu
oh it's magic i think i think there's
another one
there's another one yeah oh yeah this is
from we over prepared today dr darcy
lewis r.i.p to my friend and mentor dr
jane foster also where is her body thor
bring her back you piece of [ __ ] we want
to bury her
that's so dark i guess she went to
linkedin to ask me for it yeah what the
hell oh my god hey it's september 1st oh
my
last month of the break room was very
fun and we wanted to just cap off uh
august with our clip of the month
because we forgot that oh clip of the
month
of the month can we roll that clip is it
still on the board
might
thank you so much for watching
hit that like button notification
[ __ ]
thank you